Speaker 1: I want to very quickly look at
this very strange interview.
We I didn't see this until yesterday.
We covered, Oh sorry, I hit my microphone
there.
We covered this Trump rally that took place
in Florence, Arizona, over the weekend.
We covered the rally itself, and we talked
about it earlier this week on the show.
But there was this interview done by Newsmax
of Trump seemingly at the rally.
And it is, of course, Trump's visibly sweaty
and disheveled his shirt.
So but you know the guy just a mess.
But it is very clear that Trump is on a warpath
on a war footing, we might say, against Mitch
McConnell and sort of what he sees as the
establishment Republican Party.
Not very favorable to him.
Let's look at some of these clips.
This is a very interesting interview here.
Trump addressing Fauci and his handling of
the pandemic.
Speaker 2: We heard some lock him up chants
for Dr. Fauci out there.
What about holding Dr. Fauci accountable?
Speaker 3: Well, he is accountable.
He's somebody that has done some pretty poor
work, you know, with me.
He wanted to keep it open to China, keep it
open to Europe.
We would have lost hundreds of thousands more
people.
Speaker 1: Now it's important to remember
that even, you know, some of these things
may be true by chance because Trump sometimes,
like sort of casually tell the truth, but
by mere probability.
But you know, the whole thing about thought
you wanted to keep it open.
There was a brief period during which Fauci
was saying, Mr. President, Sir, I'm unsure
whether stopping flights is really going to
contain this.
And Fauci was sort of right.
I mean, yeah.
So even every single one of these statements
could really be looked at in more detail,
and they're they're really not truths.
Speaker 3: But he wasn't a big factor in my
administration, but Biden has made them a
big factor, and they have done a horrible
job on COVID or the China virus, as I call
it, but they've done a horrible job.
Speaker 2: What would you be doing differently
right now when it comes to COVID?
Speaker 1: It's actually a good question that
that's a good question from Newsmax,
Speaker 3: but one thing no mandates.
The mandates are killing our economy.
I'm convinced that when you have supply chain
problems, you can't get paper, you can't get
lumber, they can't build houses, they have
no nails, they have nothing.
And I think to start off with the mandates,
there
Speaker 1: is no evidence at all that vaccine
requirements at businesses are what is causing
supply chain issues.
There's just no evidence of that disaster.
Speaker 3: And people just aren't working.
You can't get people to work because of the
mandate.
So that would be the first thing I do because
Speaker 1: almost a non-factor, as you as
many of you know, we have seen that mandates
ultimately lead to, you know, like at most
half of one or one percent staff loss.
And there are many places where it's zero
because everybody's obviously vaccinated.
And you know, there's there's just no evidence
for what Trump is saying.
Trump also asked about the situation at the
border, which is interesting because quite
frankly, very little has changed at the border
under Joe Biden.
Speaker 2: We got a charged up crowd out there,
and they're very excited to see you very excited
to see Kerry like there's going to be an important
state in 2022.
What do you think is the most important election
issue for the voters of 2022 in Arizona?
Speaker 3: I think the borders for Arizona
certainly are not, you know, the whole country
is a border.
If you think about it, you know, they're pouring
throughout the country, but not really.
For Arizona and Texas in particular, the borders
are a terrible, terrible problem.
We have millions of people coming into our
country
Speaker 1: now understand that there has been
no major change to the dynamics at the border
in terms of people coming in other than there
was a period in 2020 due to the pandemic where
movement in general was down.
And so you combine the seasonality of border
crossings with the pandemic.
There was a lull and then it resumed and it
started resuming in December of 2020 and January
of 2021, even when Donald Trump was still
president, continued under Biden.
So there's the seasonality aspect and the
pandemic aspect, but there's not been this
according to the right and people like Trump.
The day Biden took office, everything changed
at the border and it was like wide open.
Come on in.
And it's just not true.
Speaker 3: You know, many are coming from
prisons of other countries over a hundred
and twenty nine countries.
They said last week that people from 129 countries,
it's not just like Mexico and Honduras and,
you know, et cetera.
They had a hundred and twenty nine countries.
Speaker 1: So Trump still very confused about
everything but as well as immigration.
And then this is where it gets very interesting.
Trump going right in on Mitch McConnell.
This is clearly a battle that Trump is not
going to give up on, and this is going to
be interesting to watch throughout 2022 when
it
Speaker 2: comes to the leadership of the
GOP right now.
What kind of letter grade would you give them?
Speaker Senate Leader McCarthy and McConnell?
Speaker 3: Well, I've been working well with
Kevin and we've been doing very well together
and we're working on the election and I'd
give him a very high mark.
Speaker 1: Now what that means is McCarthy
has mostly remained loyal to.
In my insane claims that I really won the
election, that's what Trump means by that.
Speaker 3: I'm not a fan of McConnell, I haven't
been.
I helped him get elected without me.
He would have lost his race and then he goes
and makes stupid statements after Jan. six,
Speaker 1: which and what that means is McConnell
has not remained blindly loyal to me to the
same degree as I would like to see
Speaker 3: was not my situation.
This was just a stupid thing he did, but he's
a bad leader.
He gave them two months, a two month stay
that two months of of adjustment gave them
a power that they should have never had.
So I'm not a fan of him, and I think he's
hurting the party very badly.
Speaker 1: So that is absolutely fascinating.
And it is really clear, guys, that the Trump
McConnell battle is not going to subside any
time soon.
Now, whether McConnell cares, I don't know.
I don't know how much longer Mitch McConnell
wants to be a senator.
I don't know how much he cares.
But as we get into 2022, with Trump endorsing
people and the Republican Party, of which
the Senate is a big piece, deciding how they
want to direct resources and effort, including
financial and public relations resources,
this McConnell versus Trump thing could get
very, very interesting.
My interest in it is very it's.
It's self-centered, quite frankly, it's selfish.
I want there to be as much chaos between the
Trump and the McConnell wings of the Republican
Party as possible with the hope that it'll
mess them up.
And with the hope that it will make it difficult
for them to do well in November, that's my
priority.
Let me know your thoughts on that.
You can find me on Twitter at De Packman.
We'll take a break and what a program we have
for you today.
Remember that you can support The David Pakman
Show by grabbing a membership at Join Pacman
dot com, it's cheap, it's easy, it feels very
good, and you can use the coupon code.
Wow.
Twenty two to get a borderline illegal discount
off of your membership.
Join Pacman dot com is the place to do it.